welcome to this joint session of the
afro select committee we're joined by
colleagues from the environmental audit
select committee and from the business
and energy select committee including
their their chairs we're very pleased
that such short notice that uh Witnesses
could come along uh we've got some
fairly um pointed questions to ask I
know there's been a lot of media
interest in this particular session so
perhaps if I could start off by asking
um Mr Cochran I suppose have you been at
Thames the longest of the three
Witnesses
would you say you have so maybe I can
ask by some so where did it go so
horribly wrong
um so I was brought in with a whole new
executive team to to turn around this
business
um this business matters
it says 15 million customers it went
wrong before you arrived and you were
trying to fix things my our job is
collectively to turn this business
around
we we know uh the performance both
operationally and financially hasn't
been where it needs to be we've been
very transparent about that
we are very focused on turning this
business around ensuring it remains
financially resilient and delivers a
better service for our customers and
improves it's both both it's operational
and environmental performance
so when serpently left did she
give a reason was it because she felt
that the the she was failing to deliver
that turn around or the the the demands
placed by shareholders or investors were
unacceptable did she give any sort of
explanation when she went could I
perhaps yes yes sir Adrian thank you
welcome so we should have had our
Witnesses introduce themselves before so
Alistar just just introduce yourself in
your role sorry I admitted to do that
beginning well thank you so I am um the
interim co-ceo of Thames and also the
Chief Financial Officer thank you and
Catherine yeah I'm the other interim
co-ceo of Thames with Al uh and my uh
substantive role is uh director of
strategy and external affairs
Australian as of Monday I am the new
chairman of Thames okay you're going to
come in on that to the point I
understand thank you
um I think Sarah's origination was a
surprise I think she had got to the
point perhaps of feeling uh that the
burns of office were quite considerable
um and uh it was an entirely personal
decision with which I think we had no no
involvement
so you've been unable to raise the one
billion you need to maintain your
financial position
what impact will this have a way of your
investors being unwilling to support you
let's if I can pick that up so
um we have very patient shareholders um
and they have been incredibly supportive
of this business
they have already
provided 500 million pounds of equity
this year in March which is fully drawn
by the company
they have offered what is the largest
Equity support package to the UK water
industry since privatization the form of
750 million pounds for uh in the next
two years and they've indicated that a
further two and a half billion of equity
would be would be required to turn this
business around in the next price
control period between 2025 and 2030. so
there have been incredibly supportive to
the specific question of why 750 million
now not the billion that was indicated
before
um first of all as I say it's a bigger
commitment in our good and secondly it
reflects the phasing of when the company
needs the money so we will continue to
spend as planned 11.5 billion pounds in
real terms this regulatory period
there's no change in that but
practically we cannot spend efficiently
the any more than 750 million pounds in
this price control period
um
so it supports our record levels of
investment in customer service in
operational performance in environmental
performance but we're getting the money
when we need it and in practice we we
Face a number of very practical problems
around deliverability
um so the phasing reflects what we can
deliver efficiently there are well
documented supply chain constraints
affecting the industry ourselves and the
UK and we have a very very significant
investment program we are effectively
spending one percent of the UK's
construction we're offsted off off what
wrong when they said that you needed to
raise a billion to deliver on your
investment plan
now I thought was simply I think
repeating what was indicated this time
last year that would be required now
what what shareholders said in June 2022
was they provided commitment for 500
which we've now drawn they indicated
that another billion may be required for
this price control period and that
further Equity may may be required
beyond that what we have
um now announced is
in addition to the 500 we've drawn 750
for this amp which is what we can
efficiently spend on behalf of customers
at a further indicatively two and a half
billion subject to the price control
determination in the in the next period
I suppose if I was a a shareholder of
Thames water and I guess sort of every
University lecturer in the country lots
of people working in Ontario our shells
I'd be worried about the situation with
regards to my investment and any likely
dividends
I might be less worried if I was also
the the organization carrying the debt
so to what extent are the the your
lenders the banks and other
organizations that have lent you this
massive 80 of the uh of these sort of
size of the company are they the same
people as as your shareholders or have
you gone on to sort of
why do financial markets to raise the
money
we have a very Diversified sources of
funding but many of them in the UK
are the same individuals so Pension
funds also
lend money in the form of debt Capital
as well so you're right to highlight
that our owners our shareholders over
three quarters of them actually are
Pension funds in the UK and Canada
predominantly and therefore we are very
mindful that we need to ensure that we
deliver them return so they can pay
their pensioners their pensions was it a
little bit like the sort of cause we
Origins might have if my wife lent me
hundred thousand pounds to buy a new
tractor and I pay a a an interest rate
above and beyond the market I wouldn't
be too worried about that because it's
all within the same families is that
sort of situation because that
characterize how some of your debt is
structured within the company I don't
think so um we actually raised debt very
very efficiently so our effective cash
cost of our debts last year was 2.3
percent which is very very low that
reflects our
balance sheet the strength of that
balance sheet are investment grade
credit rating so critically this
industry relies on investing for the
long term for the benefit of half your
debt is linked to inflation which of
course has risen dramatically since last
year I can remember all more than a
decade ago having a meeting with kelder
group who ran Yorkshire water at the
time and they were borrowing money at a
higher rate of interest and I could
borrow money as a simple peasant farmer
in North Yorkshire
I can't speak for obviously that
situation but um what I can say is 97 of
our debt is fixed in real or normal
terms that's part of a prudent strategy
to ensure that we manage our interest
costs so we as I said our total cash
interest cost last year was only 235
million pounds
that reflects a conscious policy to
ensure that we do hedge the risk of
interest rates amongst other things and
inflation but half your debt is is
linked to inflation so that's um that's
you know you're more like you know the
person with a mortgage who finds that
the renewals come up then somebody who's
fixed it in for five years at the sort
of rates you could get last year and for
the previous seven or eight years indeed
but like all companies you know we
ultimately have to borrow money at the
prevailing rate when we borrow new money
and will reflect the bank of England's
interest rates
at the time okay thanks Alan Brown yeah
thanks here
um
which terms what are debt and how much
has been paid in dividends since
privatization
so
um current level of net debt is 14
billion pounds that compares to a
regulator Capital value the value of the
business of 19 billion pounds which
gives you the 77 gearing rate
um in total
um dividends that left the company since
privatization is about three billion
pounds if you compare that to how much
Equity investment that's been that has
been already
put into the business and or will be put
into business as part of this Equity
support package that's about four
billion pounds so in essence the current
set of shareholders have who haven't
taken any dividend at all will be
committing best part of 14 4 billion
pounds of equity to this business
looks much higher factors and dividends
is up for about being robust but even
then that's four billion that's paid the
shareholders that could have invested
housewares
indeed but we're investing almost a
record 1.8 billion this last year we
will maintain those record levels of
investment going forward and in fact we
fully expect investment levels to have
to increase because the next price
control as we uh as we seek to improve
asset resilience but also is that
dividends to external shareholders or to
actual
um the sort of core investors in the
company we're talking about that was
total dividends to to
um uh so last year for example we paid
45 million pounds to to service debt
um at the at the the ultimate holding
company
to be absolutely clear our shareholders
our current shareholders have taken no
dividends since 2017. by the revenue
figures roughly 33 they creates the
dividends
sorry roughly 33 of your debt is
equivalent to dividends it's been paid
out
in
in that simple math absolutely that's
great can I ask about 10 sideways how it
funded
that's funded by an entirely different
Regulatory and price control
it's not funded by Thames it's it's a
different company there's independent of
Thames and there's this Thames investors
getting returns from Thames Hardware
not directly
um it's also independent regulator asset
base model how much cheapers are made
that because that's obviously underpin
with the UK wide X chair cover
or is your question oh Tim stayed with
the infrastructure is funded under our
regulated assay based model which is
risk sharing with the UK taxpayer how
much of our benefit does that run
as I understand it
um helped reduce the cost of funding of
that project pretty much I I don't know
you'd have to ask tide away what was the
original estimate for Tim Steven what
was the current
construction estimate as I say I'm not
the best person to ask is is an entirely
independent company
yeah definitely getting any more alerts
here thank you very much if we could
just move on to Philip Dunn who chairs
the environmental audit select committee
you've been very involved in water
quality particularly in our Rivers thank
you chair I'd like to touch a bit on
some of the regulatory challenges that
the company faces I think Mr Cochran you
became Finance director after the record
fine of 20 million pounds in 2017 for
sewage leakage and then the pay
repayment to customers 120 million
pounds for uh water supply leakage
problems but you were in post last week
when the company was again fined over
three million pounds by off what for
deliberately misleading of what uh
according to the the citation is there a
culture of ignoring regulatory
requirements in the company
sorry pick it up would you mind um yes
so yes there is a culture at all yes you
want to answer the question yes I'm
going to pick that pick up your question
and answer it so you're right so last
week we had the decision from the judge
in the Crawley prosecution case
um that case dates back to 2017 uh so it
is rather rather historical in in nature
um there is no doubt that we caused a
serious pollution incident in the
Crawley stream we've apologized
unreservedly uh for that
um the judge in that case did find that
we had deliberately misled the
environment agency
um I have been through the case style
I've read everything I I don't see that
but obviously we completely respect the
judge's decision in terms of your point
on culture I think one of the things
that we've done over the past couple of
years particularly under Sarah's
leadership has been to really change the
values and behaviors and the culture
across the company I think historically
we were a company in which bad news
traveled upwards too slowly I think
people were afraid actually to say how
things really were on the ground and I
think that's one of the things that
we've achieved actually over the past
couple of years has really been to turn
that around and it's really helping us
to be honest actually within the company
about the challenges that we face so
that we can really address them and make
improvements are you included within the
companies being investigated by off
water Environment Agency for breaches of
Licensing for service discharges and how
many cases are being investigated at the
moment at the moment we've got two large
investigations so we've got one uh being
conducted by the environment agency in
relation to compliance with political
treatment and then we've got another one
being conducted by offwat on the same
issue and I believe off what is also
contemplating whether we're in breach of
section 94 of the water industry act
which is obviously the Parisian of
effectual drainage they are considering
multiple instances under that broad
heading but there are just those two
investigations the off would have
indicated with the Iran's agency they're
looking at over 2 000 breaches across
the industry can you indicate to the
community What proportion of that if you
haven't got a specific number yeah I
don't have the specific number with me I
mean I certainly think that tens would
represent a large portion of that we
have been very open and transparent
about the extent to which we are
discharging untreated sewage into rivers
we've also said that that is
unacceptable and we've been fully
Cooperative with the investigations that
are being run both by our Fort and the
environment agency final question for me
Chad the government have announced today
that they're removing
cap on fines for breaches of license
permits what have you made any
assessment yet what you think that might
mean for Thames water in the event that
these investigations lead to fines we
haven't assessed the the impact of that
particular change no I mean the one
thing that I would say though is that
although I can understand why the
government is doing what it's doing we
are committed to becoming more compliant
with this legislation we're committed to
delivering better against the
expectations of the public in respect of
River Health and almost regardless of
the level of financial penalties we
would stay committed to those goals
because it's simply the right thing to
do and that's what the public expect
this is a culture change that we can
look to for the future which is Alice I
assume you endorse absolutely I mean I
think that you know respecting our
environmental obligations
respecting our obligations regarding
drinking water these are the fundamental
bedrocks on which a successful company
culture is based and actually I think
one of the
one of the important sort of
contributory factors is the culture of
the people at the coal face
it's probably mixing my metaphors and I
think when you talk to I started to talk
to people on the ground they are very
committed to customer service
and they are the best advocates for the
business we must Empower them and let
them do their business going forward
because of which to speak up a little
please um thank you
thank you just I think going back to
what you said about it was it was a leak
at near Gatwick wasn't it where lots of
fish were killed and I've read some of
it and it was it was a genuine had a
mistake or a technical fault that caused
the problem that the problem was the the
cover-up afterwards and I think um the
the judge Christine Lang Casey said she
believed and I quote there would have
been a deliberate attempt to mislead the
environment agency by emitting water
readings and submitting a report to the
regulator design denying responsibility
are you saying you you don't agree with
that you said it was it was it
accidental it wasn't delivered it was
accidental that the the the misleading
readings were given and and the
responsibility was denied let me let me
recap and first let me say I absolutely
accept the judge's decision there's no
equivocation with with the judge's
findings but what happened in that case
was that we had two pumps working to
pump sewage in in the sewage treatment
works and one of them started to work
constantly to pump sewage directly from
uh where the sewage came into the
stormwater tank we're not denying that
that there was a technical thought it
was the the cover-up which I think the
judge was drawing attention to and then
the attempt to mislead off what about
what actually had happened I mean to
clarify it was the environment agency
rather than awful but the the point
still stands so what happened was we
actually conducted two separate
investigations into what happened
following this malfunction of a pump
on one of those investigations concluded
that there were multiple factors that
could have contributed to the pollution
incident and it wasn't clear that it was
our error and a different investigation
conducted by a different team concluded
that it was in fact to do with an error
that was made by Thames water not to
sort out the malfunctioning pump those
two investigations happened in parallel
they were conducted by separate teams
those teams did not talk to each other
when we were asked to submit our
investigation to the environment agency
the investigation that got submitted was
in fact the one that had said that it
wasn't our fault
um in fact what should have happened is
that we should have sent both of those
investigations and all the underlying
data to the environment agency which in
due course we then did right
um but of course it transpired that what
appeared if you were looking at this
from the environment agency's point of
view is that Thames of water had said
that it wasn't its fault when it knew
that it was its fault and I can see how
that how that comes across I can
absolutely see that how that comes
across I I think it was um I think it
was an error on our part rather than a
deliberate intention to mislead but I
completely respect the findings of the
judge
it's very early days for me I've been in
the chair for two days
but I got a lot of experience of dealing
with other utilities and I think the
change could you speak up please I'm
sorry the change that needs to occur
within Thames is to treat all our
Regulators as partners we must have an
open book basis with The Regulators
women's treat them as
people who have the interests of the
industry and actually of terms of
customers at heart and just help them by
being very transparent in what we do
that is the tone I think that we need to
set from the top okay thank you Barry
Garner yes um Mr Cochran
you've painted it to my colleagues a
very uh good picture of the the state of
the company at the moment but in May of
this year JP Morgan's report said it
took poor financial performance you've
been the finance director finance
officer for uh since 2021 weak
operational performance a stretched
balance sheet uh it talked about the
Enforcement cases coming from off what
and uh pretended stricter off what
dividend policy coming in the future
um
of your staff you've now chosen to make
redundant that was on the 20th of June
just a month after that report are they
paying the price for your failure
I think we have been very clear indeed
on on Monday when we released our
results that our operational financial
performance wasn't where I needed to be
um we've been very transparent about
that we know we need to improve
performance for our customers we haven't
been transparent about that for the past
two years have you since you've been
Financial director let's look at the the
figure that you discussed with my
colleague earlier you know 14 billion
pounds of debt
um I think actually note 18 of your
account shows that your borrowings are
15.7 billion how does that reconcile
with the 14 billion that you were
talking about earlier 14 billion just to
be absolutely clear is our statutory
measure of net debt net debt
um it for Covenant calculation purposes
which is what we report in terms of
gearing it's 14.7 billion and that takes
account of what is called debt accretion
the additional costs for hedging
inflation and other risks that was 14.5
isn't it
14.7
14.5 takes the form of your whole
business securitization a structure that
you've used to borrow against your
highly regulated assets so a net there
on a covenant basis is 14.7
um that as I say Compares so to get to
the 77 of gearing which is the lowest
level of gearing in the lot in the last
decade that we announced this week sorry
the lowest level gearing in the last
decade that you've announced but the
second highest in the sector
indeed but yeah indeed and the off what
when you were regulating of what
controlling off what was
um I thought you said that the the uh
ratio should be sixty percent
not 77 not 80.
is that not the case you said it should
be sixty percent well this
all the scaring that we were using when
I was at off water in fact off what's
been using right up until the last price
review is the notional level of gearing
that off what uses to input into the
formula that users determine the
weighted average cost of capital so did
you recommend 60 yes you did didn't you
no we were using a 60 assumption for the
purposes of calculating the wasted
average cost of capital and a price
control so you weren't concerned at all
that at that period the company had over
80 percent
our view at the time and I I will fully
acknowledge that views have moved on but
our view at the time was that a
company's choice of capital structure
was a matter for the company itself and
that the shareholders bore the risk of
that now obviously views have moved on
since then was the view at the time
right so now that the views have moved
on what discussions have you had with
the government on the potential
nationalization of your company no no
why do you think it's being talked about
in the Press so freely
well I can say that over the last couple
of weeks I've read a lot in the Press
some of that was rather more outlandish
than perhaps we would have liked I think
one of the things that may be outlandish
maybe Mr Cochrane can come to this is
the way in which you've structured uh
what was it 560 million pounds of debt
just in the case that the government
should have to take over the company
do you want to comment on that Mr which
debt are you referring to this is that
the amount of money that would be
payable from your debt uh should the
government the government would have to
pay 560 million pounds off to your your
share in your debtors
um I I I don't recognize that figure but
um yeah I think what Barry's referring
to is when um Mr Corbin is leader of the
labor party and there were Manifesto
commitments to I think I'll say it in my
own words chair thank you very much okay
um there was uh talk about the
nationalization of the water company at
that time
um but actually since then public
opinions moved on public opinion has
actually gone from 79 of people opposed
to the nationalization now to 83 because
of the way in which your companies have
been failing
um to to meet the Public's expectations
um so nationalization uh seems to be a
pretty popular thing amongst the public
and maybe that's referenced in the Press
um
but my question is about the way in
which you included a clause in a
previous debt issue that would require
the government to immediately pay off
around half billion pounds of debt in
the case of nationalization
you don't recognize that Clause don't
recognize that closely okay in that case
perhaps you could sorry sir Adrian you
you seem to want to come in there I was
going to address the question of
nationalization okay if we can just
finish finish off with Mr Cochran first
um if you could write to us tell us in
fact was such a clause included in a
previous debt issue if it was why was it
and what would the implications of that
have been for the uh for the government
thank you I'll do that yes sir agent I
was going to address your question on
nationalization
if you go back
to the very dawn of the private
ownership of these utilities
the rationale was
to empower the utilities to borrow
privately
to use private sector capabilities
performance through the uh operation of
utilities we say that we have much water
do in that area
but I think the key thing is removed
from the treasury the burden of funding
the improvements of orders sector that
we're now managing privately and that
was the driver of privacy but the
problem sir Adrian has been that
actually the although there has been
substantial investment in the
infrastructure since privatization I
absolutely agree with you on that it
hasn't been enough has it and that's
exactly the point of my colleague Mr
Dunn's questions to to your colleague
earlier and indeed we've got to increase
the flow of that investment that's what
our refinancing package is aiming to do
what your structure the structure of the
company not when you were there but what
the structure of the company allowed was
for an Australian Bank to actually
leverage the fact that your regulated
asset to extract money you did not yes I
think that there was a flow of dividends
from the company under previous
ownership it's for us quite a long time
ago Mr Gardner I think it reflected
slightly it reflects the state of the
company now or doesn't it thread it
reflects I think the state of what the
markets were and the practices at that
time
um I can't I can't those practices are
still going on aren't they I can't
Corey's doing the same in other
regulated Industries and actually you
yourself I believe uh are on one of
macquarie's companies cadent and and
actually Catherine Ross
um is on British grass transmission
aren't you National Gas transmission not
national grass transition which are both
Macquarie companies
there's a very cozy Arrangement here I
have to correct you Mr Gardner they are
not Macquarie companies they have a
range of international investors in them
including in my case Chinese and Qatari
investors
um they're all very responsible
investors they're all seeking to perform
improve the performance of the companies
that is the case here it was probably
the case with Macquarie owned a major
stake in the company I can't answer that
myself
but this was ancient history relatively
speaking ancient history for us as
Macquarie exited in 2017. well you and I
have a different definition of ancient
siraging thank you reflections
thank you uh Rosie I think you wanted to
come with the supplementary on that
question thank you very much just
following on from uh Barry Gardner's
question
278 418 people have now signed the
petition to bring water companies back
into National ownership and I helped my
constituents deliver that to Downing
Street around Christmas last year
because it was started by a group in my
constituency just leaving aside you know
the idea that you don't think that that
would work because obviously you don't
um do you understand why the public
would like to see our government or
whoever being responsible for the water
company so that everything's transparent
it's not as though we can shop around as
customers it's a vital utility we don't
know who all these investors are from
foreign companies that own our utilities
can you understand any of you or all of
you why the public want transparency so
we don't have to do inquiries like this
I think that um
public ownership
seems to be the answer to many questions
I think when you conduct a real
evaluation I think private ownership is
still the way forward I mean that's a
personal belief by being associated with
private sector operations all my life
I can understand the frustration of
customers you want to see improvements
we would love to be able to deliver all
those improvements overnight but it will
take time we will try very hard to bring
the customers with us our Frontline
employees serve customers every day
they're very much in touch with
everything that happens on the ground
we also need to be in touch with things
that happen on the ground and we've got
to improve our standing with customers
we're absolutely agreed on it but I
think the way is continuing the private
sector model not reverting to the public
sector that will be my instinct I came
in on the ground in whitstable in my
constituencies lots of poo and sewage so
it'd be nice to improve that anyone else
want to come in
I mean the only thing I would add is
there is a obviously a perfectly
reasonable National policy debate about
ownership models I think that's
perfectly legitimate that's absolutely
normal in a democracy
um our job attends this is what Adrian
was talking about is is to keep the Taps
flowing and the lose flushing into
improve our performance under whatever
model the government of the day decides
and that's what we'll keep focusing on
thank you Rosie Derek Thomas thank you
Tim Catherine we've just heard your
chairman talk about wanting a closer
relationship or partnership with Road
used between Thames water and off what
Euro previous chief executive so does
the relationship that is aspired to this
partnership and does a trend of off what
staff seeking high paid positions in
Industry affect the ability to regulate
water companies yeah so the first thing
just to be really clear on which I I'm
sure you you know is uh I left off what
in January 2018 I went to work for BT
for three and a half years before I then
applied for the role at Thames water so
there was quite a gap between me leading
off what and joining Thames which is
quite important
um I mean personally I think that there
is an important role for better
understanding between companies and the
regulator about what each is trying to
achieve and about how the how the regime
works I mean I I'm immensely proud of my
time at off what I think off what people
do an incredibly difficult job every day
they're very passionate about the water
section wanting to deliver for customers
and I think for me to come into the
water company and a water company which
is facing very considerable challenges
and a massive turnaround but bringing
that understanding of what the regulator
is trying to achieve which is actually
you know very much in common with what
we're trying to do at Thames uh is is
helpful and I think that Mutual
understanding is is beneficial thank you
for it um so while you were typically
Chief exec you delivered a strategy on
building trust and confidence in water
services has that been delivered it's a
work in progress
um and so I'm a West common MP so you
might understand why I asked that
question what was your view on
um macquarie's approach to Thames water
while you were CEO of off between 2013
we've covered it briefly but in terms of
their relationship and their the way
they built up debt was that a concern
when you're a chief exit yeah so let me
let me just sort of go back
time which
as I said before it does feel like quite
a different world actually I think
things have moved on a lot so when I
when I joined off what
um as I said before it the the the
Zeitgeist at the time was very much that
decisions around capital structure were
a matter for companies and their
investors and their investors were on
risk for that
um and that as a regulator
um we would keep a weather eye on things
and we would be ready to act but only
when acting was really necessary so
things like the requirement and licenses
to maintain an investment grade credit
rating was was really important but
beyond that if a company chose to Gear
Up essentially its Equity was bearing
more risk and that was a choice for its
Equity now I think you know even as I
was sort of just leaving offwards of
2017-ish and then after I left in 2018.
I think views moved on quite
considerably and as you've seen in more
recent years off what's taken a Keener
interest in what it calls Financial
resilience which is a broader concept
and then as part of that in capital
structures that then culminated in more
recent license modifications so given
that Financial resistance and then
extraordinary pressure on Thames water
today
do you expect or intend to increase
customer bills in the near future well
in the near future not so we're
currently in in the current price
control uh settlement that was
established by our fort in 2019 so the
off what can't reopen that and so those
price limits will hold until 2024 so we
remain restricted by the pr 19.
yeah exactly now Beyond then and I think
we we've already talked about this there
is no doubt and Thames is not alone here
there is no doubt that there is a
substantial need for more investment in
the sector as a whole including intense
and we've said repeatedly we have an
aging asset base we have assets that
aren't as resilient as our customers and
the environment would expect them to be
we also have a lot of new infrastructure
that we need to invest in to meet the
challenges of climate change adaptation
and population change and so that that
will need to be funded and it is an
unfortunate truth that the only source
of ultimate funding for that in the
current model is the customer now the
really important thing is that we as a
water company are as efficient as we
possibly can be so that a customer does
not pay a pound more than they need to
but it's also important our previous
conversation that we can access Capital
markets so that we can finance that
investment and smooth the cost over
decades rather than basically having to
recover all of that cost in let's say a
five-year period in which case the bills
will be substantially higher so agent
and hearing all that and understanding
that at the moment if you'd put prices
up if the customers would feel they're
just paying for the failure in terms of
water actually the work you need to do
between now and next year are you
how are you going to approach that to
restore trust so that when people's
bills increase potentially that actually
recognizes to pay for the service
they've received not the way the
companies run I think there are two
elements in this
we're going to deliver on our promises
and we've been much better at
communicating with customers
it's a long hard road but that's what we
will have to do thank you thank you Jim
thank you very much indeed
um can we ask Darren to come in let's
check his chair of the business and
energy committee so we're pleased to
have you as our guest thank you sir
Robert good morning everybody
um Catherine Ross in 2014 as the chief
executive of the water regulator you
signed off the business plans for the
water companies didn't you I did and you
just said that at that time you thought
it was okay for those companies to
increase their debts because it was
their risk is that right
what would have happened at that time if
any of the water companies went bankrupt
oh gosh right so just let's just take a
step back
um and if you could ask my question if a
company during the time when you were
CEO went bust what would have happened
yeah so what would have happened in the
event of the bankruptcy or insolvency is
that the special Administration regime
that set out in the legislative
framework would would kick in that is a
decision for the Secretary of State I
mean when I was at off what our
expectation would have been that we
would advise on that but it would have
been a decision as I think it still is
for the Secretary of State in plain
English that means that it would have to
be nationalized and taxpayers would have
had to pick up the bill that's right
isn't it
not necessarily well especially special
special administrative regime either you
sell the business to someone else as a
going concern as we've seen in the
failure of the energy Market all the
government has to pick up the bill as it
had to do with bowl of energy so
ultimately the taxpayer would have been
on the hook wouldn't they well in the
event that the come company couldn't be
sold as a going concern yes there will
be some liabilities that would have to
be met and they could be met by the
taxpayer or they could be passed on to
Futures depending on the regulatory
regime at the time right we're here
today because Thames water which you now
run is in a position where the
government is having to plan to
renationalize you because of a failure
of your finances but you've signed off
as the chief executive of the regulator
in 2014 for Macquarie to ramp up the
debt from 3 billion to 10 billion pounds
while taking out nearly 3 billion pounds
in dividends often paying dividends
higher than the profits the company made
in particular years the reason we're in
this position and the reason that
taxpayers are now potentially on the
hook for billions of billions of pounds
of national borrowing is because you as
the chief executive of the regulator and
the regulator failed in delivering your
statutory duties do you want to
apologize to the public Miss Ross I
don't accept that characterization of
off what's price control in in 2014 the
other thing I would say is well is
special Administration is obviously a
matter for the government but special
Administration is very much a nuclear
option there is a very very high bar on
the government deciding to put a company
into special Administration and one of
those triggers would be insolvency and
the other one would be you know perhaps
persistent and severe breach of our
license now we are not close to either
of those two triggers and you heard our
CFO talking a little while ago the fact
about the fact that we have 4.4 billion
pounds of liquidity we are a long way
off that insolvency trigger and I think
a long way off the conditions for
special Administration being that okay
good ideas to add something when I'm
ready for surgeon sorry forgive me um so
Miss Ross you just said in the 2014
price review you didn't accept that
characterization but you've just
admitted to the committee that you
signed off the business plans that
allowed Macquarie to increase the debt
which has got Thames water into the
position it's it's been in the regulator
facilitated this problem didn't it let
me let me clarify so in 2014 uh the off
board not just the authorship executive
issues issued a set of final
determinations that that is correct what
those final determinations actually did
was set out what the company needed to
deliver for its customers and the
environment and also the amount of money
that they could recover from their
customers to do that that is all they
did and then of course the incentive uh
framework that off what puts around that
determines the amount of money that the
company actually makes now of what
policy at that time which has moved on
but off what policy at that time was
that if a company made a profit under
that regular regulatory regime it was up
to the company to decide what it did
with that so if it chose to pay that
profit out of the company in
distributions it was for you to do that
and
Ms Ross let me ask the question in a
different way two of the statutory
obligations of off what the regular
regular water regulator when it was set
up was one to protect the interests of
customers and two to make sure the
privatized water companies could Finance
themselves on both of those measures Are
you seriously telling the committee
today that you as the chief executive
the regulator at the time succeeded in
delivering those statutory obligations
in the context that you're before the
committee today are you really saying
that was a success I think at the time
when I was at off ward and I believe it
to be true today everybody at off what
takes their statutory duties incredibly
serious what did you perform them we
were exercising our functions in pursuit
of our statutory duties whether every
decision we made was perfect with the
benefit of hindsight possibly not but
that's exactly what we were trying with
the benefit of hindsight would you like
to apologize to the tax preparer for
being here and potentially putting them
in this position where yet again another
regulated market could potentially
collapse and expose taxpayers to
billions of pounds I think if you're
asking for an apology from
asking for an apology from you Ms Ross I
won't apologize for my role okay
thank you
Darren I think Barry wanted to come in
with another quick point just on the the
question that my colleagues just raised
and if you go through special
Administration then of course the
shareholders take the hit of the company
isn't financially viable and that's
that's what shareholders are fought in
that of course relates to the 560
million question earlier
um but the process need not
be renationalization as such you could
actually set up Regional local Authority
bodies to take over
and transfer the company as a growing
concern to those Regional local
authorities could you not
I think that would be possible yes and
and actually that is the way in which
many countries in the rest of the world
actually from their water industry isn't
it I mean there is as I said before
there is a perfectly reasonable debate
to be had about the right out structural
internship model the question was simple
it was that is the way that many other
countries in the world run their water
industry is it yes there are a variety
of models and that's one of them and and
and they do it actually more
successfully in many cases than we
happen to have done don't they can't
comment on that well in terms of the the
questions that my colleague Philip Dunn
put to you earlier
um I haven't got the comparative
information about the political
performance of different regimes
thank you chair thank you just a couple
of final questions um
obviously um
you've got very high levels of gearing
as we've already mentioned and but
you've just talked about you know
long-term Investments and how you're
looking at decades ahead so do you think
it was a mistake by the company to have
so much of it does if steps about 50
actually linked to inflation rather than
taking out more long-term deals giving
it such a long-term business and was
that done maybe because
um the people then knew the company were
so closely connected to the company and
I know you've sort of referred to that
but you know is it the case that
actually the shareholders cope without a
dividend because they're getting these
interest payments in many cases
well we manage our balance sheet to to
to to reflect the period in which we're
investing in so we have debt that's up
to 40 years in tenor the average age is
about 13.
um critically the shareholders have put
in additional Equity to ensure we retain
that strong balance sheet so that we
continue to be able to borrow money at a
efficient rate of interest
and do so your credit ratings of bonds
the blades haven't they the how can we
still retain an investment grade credit
rating a triple B credit rating which is
a strong investment grade rating that
allows us to borrow money efficiently
and therefore we can keep customer bills
down
I think I think Alan Brown would come in
a quick Point yes
about dividends and we've got a briefing
look at Thames Utilities in terms work
utilities
and accounts it shows that cumulative
dividends paid out 7.2 billion so why
did you have a much lower figure
let me provide you the analysis
um after this committee
yeah that'd be very good
thank you finally I just ask yes please
fill in quickly on that specific point
it would be very helpful if you could in
your reply on dividend payments separate
those which are payments to equity
shareholders those which are
characterized as dividends in the
accounts but actually our rep are within
the financing structure funding debt
payments yes
thinking that if the statement about uh
not our shareholders haven't taken a
dividend it was only referring to the
the normal shareholders not the debt
finances yeah that's absolutely correct
they haven't taken any income for their
investment that's right
and Miss Ross having been both involved
with off water and obviously turns water
do you think the remit evolved could be
extended to look maybe a little more
deeply into the sort of the financing
structures within water companies rather
than just sort of the relationship
between the the sort of provider and the
and the customer too to get a bit better
picture of just where that debt is and
how exposed you might be because
obviously I don't think
um most people were aware that you were
so exposed to high inflation in terms of
debt repayments
um in terms of upwards remit I mean I
think that's exactly what off what's
been doing in recent years I mean you
can ask them more about it because
that's carried on off after I left but
but certainly from about 2017 if I'm
recalling certainly through 2018 and
more recently they have been paying a
lot more attention to what what they
refer to as Financial resilience and
part of that is is about gearing and the
appropriateness of the capital structure
for the sort of investment programs that
are needed and I think that's entirely
appropriate okay thank you and just
before we let you go
um Mr Cochran you talked about 151
redundancies
are those going to be voluntary
redundancies could you give an assurance
because obviously it'll be people
working in the company who will be
worried about their jobs in their future
will they be compulsory evidences or do
you are you confident you can fill those
advantages with other early retirement
or voluntary redundances to the best of
my knowledge we haven't announced a
redundancy program
right I I think the garage was 151
redundancies as Satan to the best of my
knowledge we have not announced a
redundancy program in fact we have been
hiring people consistently in fact we uh
for example we onshored our client
service our customer service facing team
into the region as part of our
turnaround plan and continue to insource
activity so that we can get an
operational grip on our business to help
part of this development
why when I mentioned that earlier did
you not immediately say that I'm I'm
astonished
if I may just just one further thing and
that is given that
um inflation is going to rise and your
your uh interest on your debt is going
to rise
um is it the case that prices are going
to go up for customers
indeed under the regulatory model um
prices are indexed to inflation so why
is it that you and others uh indeed in
off work have and the indeeding
government have been saying that there
is no possibility that bill payers will
see their bills rise
I think if anybody's said that
um that is not the government Minister
actually I think as well I mean the the
regulatory settlements are done on a
cpih plus well indeed yes we all know
your interest payments are going to go
up this is what's precipitated the
problem so so the question is how much
are they going to go up what do you
actually foresee the rise that that your
customers are going to have to pay as a
result of your company's failure
actually our customers are paying less
than they otherwise would as a result of
the poor operational performance of the
business because we are in penalty
territory in terms of what's incentive
regime now that means that the penalties
we pay actually translate into lower
bills than would otherwise be the case
for customers because we're not
delivering the service so we want
companies to fail in order that bill
payers don't pay as much is that what
you're saying no but the view is that
customers should pay for the service
that they receive we haven't been
providing the level of service that
customers expect and therefore we
shouldn't charge them at the prices that
we would otherwise have charged we're
talking about the interest payments on
your debt leading through to a rise in
the bills that your customers will pay
is that the case no no there is no
mechanism within the current price
control to enable us to put up bills to
reflect higher interest payments
and so your bill parents can rest
assured on the Assurance of the co-chief
executive of the company that uh the
financial difficulties that you've got
yourselves into will not result in their
bills Rising thank you very much
well thank you very much indeed for
coming and giving us evidence we'll now
move on to our second panel thank you
very much indeed to our Witnesses
the proceeding is currently suspended
Welcome to our second evidence panel
from off wet off what uh could I
actually off wet as well probably but uh
could I uh ask my the witnesses to
introduce themselves Ian I know for my
time at the department for transport of
course so uh welcome nice to see you
again so can you just introduce sales
briefly please
um this time last year so 12 months uh
David black chief executive at office
thank you very much indeed uh you can
ask Robbie Moore to start the
questioning please uh yeah thank you
chair if I said that off what is the
economic regulator of water and
wastewater sectors in England and Wales
would I be correct
yes that's right so how can I or indeed
any members of the committee sat around
here or indeed my constituents have any
confidence in offwatch when on the 29th
of June you express confidence in terms
Waters financial situation yet Thames
water's debt burden is 20 above your
recommended level
so yes so uh as as they can't regulate
it we set a uh an amount of debt uh
level in terms of when we set price
controls as what a reasonable prudent
company should have however companies
have discretion uh to to manage their
own financial affairs and so companies
make decisions about the choices they
make in terms of debt levels what we do
as a Regulators to protect customers
interests by ensuring that they do not
bear the consequences of companies
decision making and what we've done in
the last two years is to is to very much
strengthen the provisions around
companies having adequate Financial
resilience and so our concern is making
sure companies have sufficient buffer to
deal with uncertainty to deal with
events that may materialize and that's
exactly what we have done and so we have
protected customers interests customers
uh protected in terms of the bills they
pay and the services they receive and
they will remain to and so do you think
that you've acted reasonably and
responsibly and quickly enough within
the situation they're seeing with Thames
water at the moment
so Thames water are responsible and the
shareholders are responsible for for
their level of debt uh and we are
holding them to account on behalf of
customers how are you holding them to
account if we're in this situation that
we are at the moment what action have
you taken so far can I just say a few
words
um so the situation in which Thames
finds itself is a consequence of its
underperformance
um so it's got high levels of gearing we
would like to see the gearing levels
down because it does provide us as David
says a greater buffer when things go
wrong so Thames is problems the moment
being crystallized because they've got
underperformance so they are not getting
the revenue they expect because they're
delivering poor service to their
customers so the revenues are down and
their costs are higher so the
shareholders are now bearing the extra
cost which means because the lack of
resilience in the company which we are
concerned about it now needs injection
of shareholder funds so so our concern
is performance they are in the situation
because performance is not where it
needs to to be and we've got similar
issues in other companies but at Thames
their performance lab so we have been
all over them in addressing their issues
about turnaround Improvement customer
services and costs so when you say
you've been all over them why did you on
the 29th of June Express confidence in
their financial position we're only in
July now that was only last month but
we're confident that in the
conversations we've had they have got
sufficient Equity commitment coming from
the shareholders to address their
shortfalls so we we in the short term
believe that the right course of action
at this point in time because they
haven't got Financial resilience is the
shareholders to inject Equity to support
the the business as it states they off
what Express confidence in terms of
water's financial position on the 29th
of June we're now in July you are here
recognizing that they have got
challenges now with their financial
position
um Thames water has raised 750 million
of that one billion it requires you've
mentioned short term there what is the
impact going to be on customers on my
constituents and indeed constituents of
those sat around the table here that's
welcome it's before we respond to that I
think we should make very clear that in
December last year we published a report
saying we were unhappy with teams as
Financial resilience and that action was
required at that time the company had
committed to one and a half billion
pounds of equity injections and on that
basis uh we so that was the basis uh
that that was our view at that time a
level of funding because it's not that
on 29th of June we've suddenly changed
our position we were very clear and have
been clear for some time that Thames has
inadequate Financial resilience and that
they need to address that so just to be
clear on that okay so over that time
frame
Thames hasn't raised that level of
funding is that is that correct so
they've injected the 500 million pounds
as they committed to uh as recently and
it was the remaining billion pounds
which they have now uh reached uh agree
with the shoulders to support a 750
million pound Addiction in the company
so that's the change and that was our
concern and why we were engaging with
the company ahead of their financial
reports about the shielders commitment
uh and those the discussions that we've
been having with do you feel as a
regulator that you've taken sufficient
infection despite having first raised it
in December and not giving as as a
stalker warning as I would like to see
from a regulator on the 29th of June I
think our our warning in December last
year was unambiguous and clear that they
had insufficiency there was a regulator
that you've taken sufficient in a
faction since the warning that was put
out in December last year yes uh but
we're also engaged before that we were
having discussions I just shortly after
I was appointed as acting chief
executive I was discussing with the
chief exec then chief executive Thames
water about the about our concerns about
their financial resilience and it was
those con and and in terms of we have an
annual process where we look at the
company's Assurance around their
adequacy of financial resources and
about how the company was going to
demonstrate that and that was the
outcome of those conversations with the
company's commitment to inject the 1.5
billion pounds into the business so
we've been engaged with teams on their
financial resilience for some time the
cut shoulders are responding but we are
remain concerned that there are
significant issues to address and as Ian
said significant performance issues in
terms of the turnaround of the company
the how are you as a regulator going to
ensure that that chat that challenge is
addressed and their debt burden is going
to be brought down
so in terms of the first thing is for
the company is to get a plan that will
secure their their turnaround so they've
obviously made a number of tips to turn
around their business uh those haven't
succeeded at this point uh and we
continue to hold the company to account
on their performance to date and so
imposing Financial penalties on on the
company uh for their failures to deliver
for customers we have so we have a
number of licensed paths but we have
powers for example in terms of the
payment of dividends which we've just
brought into to place but we also will
examine their assurances around their
financial resilience which they have
provided to us on this past Monday and
we'll work through that and engage with
the company we will remain in discussion
with company with the company about
their ability to secure financing from
shelves
so I mean my one of my concerns is that
ultimately as a result of
Thames is poor management this is likely
to result in customer Bills going up no
can be unequivocal on that so we set
companies allowed cost of capital
allowed Returns on the basis of an
efficient well-functioning company so
Thames shareholders are up for the
additional costs associated with airport
performance and that is evidence by the
fact that I've had to inject additional
funding into the company uh and they've
had very little web dividend payments
over the last seven years so you're very
quick to come out with a no there but
over what time period does that relate
to
uh so in terms of we reset price reviews
every five years but the key point is
we're saying that we will allow Thames
the efficient costs of running the
business now that may vary and we will
set that again as part of the 2024 price
you can only confidently say no up until
2024 is that correct or beyond that not
at all because we have a policy position
so whether bills are going up or bills
are going down that will be determined
by the needs from a customer and
environmental perspective and we'll set
bills on the basis of terms as efficient
costs and an efficient cost of financing
uh that uh and so that will be the basis
for setting bills and it won't be about
teams as actual debt burden or actual
costs Tim's customers do not pay a penny
more for terms as 80 gearing versus
other companies 60 gears
thank you chair thank you I'm Jones
um thank you last year my committee did
a major inquiry into the collapse of the
energy markets and highlighted a number
of failings that the energy regulator
off gem which they're now dealing with
have you been working with off gem to
learn the lessons from the energy Market
as it relates to the water markets uh
yes uh we we welcome your report and we
have uh considered it we've also engaged
with off gym and their advisors they're
engaged with during that process so for
example we had the the consultancy they
commissioned to do the independent
review come in and speak to us in the
leadership team and talk through their
view about the Lessons Learned for
option okay so having considered my
committee's report what do you think the
main takeaway is that you need to now
change it off what to secure the future
of the water industry so we think the
key changes we have made are the are
they bringing into being of new
conditions and Company licenses around
payment of dividends and financial
resilience so under the environment act
2021 we receive new powers to main
company licenses up until that point we
didn't in our view of sufficient power
to change company licenses we have now
used those Powers the first Target erase
those Powers was around strengthening
provisions on financial resilience the
second change we're making is about
improving customer protection and
customer service in 2022 off what
started Financial monitoring of water
companies according to the review of
your 2014 price review that was
published on your website were you not
doing this before so we've published a
financial monitoring report since 2016
uh so we've published a series of
reports every year uh they come out we
look at companies financial statements
they provide us we do our analysis on a
range of uh of financing issues around
companies including their their debt
structures their dividend payments uh
and their plans
with pumpkin so we've been doing that
since 2016. and did you raise issues
about Thames water in 2016. so we
identified that they had uh high levels
of gearing that they had financial
ratios that that did raise considered
why has nothing happened about that uh
so Thames have been able to to finance
their activities and so there hasn't
been it so that so we have been engaging
with the company and we have raised
concerns about it uh but frankly our
concerns at the time are more focused on
Southern water where we have secured
injections of equity into that company
and Yorkshire water we have also secured
it positions in that company uh we have
now uh more focused on Thames uh
recognizing the issues that they're
facing but at the time those issues were
less severe uh than faced by other
companies I've just known shouldn't you
be focusing on all of the companies you
regulate one at any given time uh we we
do but the point I was making is that
we're engaged with the shareholders of
Southern at that time to uh in terms of
securing their exit from the business
and they enter into that business of new
shareholders who are able to inject a
billion pounds into Southern water in
the previous panel the new chairman of
Thames water said that we need to enter
a period of transparency where the water
companies are transparent with the
regulator the implication of that is
that they haven't been in the past is
that right
and they have provided information to us
on their financing I think what I would
say is they won't sufficiently
transparent with the public uh obviously
company financing issues are complex
we've criticized them for being opaque
we have introduced licensed conditions
to require companies to provide more
adequate financial information but I
think there's a huge challenge for
companies in collect explaining and
plain English what's going on with the
financing structures where the money is
coming from and where it's going to I
think you said that from 2025 you're
going to reduce the debt Target from 60
to 55 is that right so it's part of the
price of you yes we use a notional uh
gearing Target and that is the signal
that we think there should be prudent
Headroom in financing structures uh so
we would so we're using that to signal
to investors and companies uh that we
think their Equity buffer needs to
increase as they face the challenges of
the future they're going to be making
large investment programs they're facing
the challenges of climate change and
we're also increasing the level of
financial penalties on companies uh so
we want them to have adequate Financial
structures to bear that only three of
the 11 water companies that you regulate
have debt below 60 today what is the
consequence if they don't hit your debt
Target from 2025. and so what we're
concerned about is adequacy of financial
resilience and so that doesn't rest on
gearing alone so I think we need to be
quite clear that the gearing number is
useful could you try that in just plain
English for me so what happens if they
don't hit your debt Target what's the
consequence for the company so the the
we're not setting the Target in terms of
companies why do you call it a debt
Target if it's not a Target because
that's the basis for setting the price
review which is about making sure we're
protecting customers interest so
customers are paying a bill based on a
55 gearing Target rather than the actual
dick gearing the company has which
relates to the question earlier about
how we protect customers interests so
we're saying that we're going to set
customer bills on the spaces if
companies have different financing
structures they bear those consequences
so this is it's really important that
shareholders and companies are
responsible for their financial
structures we are here to protect
customers interests and that's what
we're doing my last question is on
consequences that you've made made the
point repeatedly that you protect
customers and you've talked about
customer builds you recognize though do
you that there is a scenario in which
the taxpayer would have to pick up the
cost of a failed water company because
they are too important to fail do you
ever think about the risk to taxpayers
of bankrupt water companies when you're
looking at protecting consumer interests
I think you're referring to the special
Administration regime so the situation
in wars with other regulated Industries
is that a special administrator will be
appointed if a company is in danger of
insolvency it is their job uh then to
deliver services to customers so click
customers interests but also to secure
new owners for the companies and in
contrasts perhaps to the energy
companies you looked at water companies
have very large asset bases and so in
the first instance we think costs around
special Administration we're born by
investors we do accept that there is a
risk for taxpayers and so that is one of
the reasons why we've been working to
drive increased Financial resilience
into companies while we've used our new
powers we've received from the
environment act uh change license
conditions to tighten up on financial
resilience the public will look at
what's being reported as happening in
the water industry having just gone
through what happened in the energy
industry last year and the risk here is
that the government taxpayers have to
borrow enormous amounts of money to
underwrite the risks that companies have
been allowed to take and the public will
see once again companies like Macquarie
cashing out walking away with their
money the previous CEO of the regulator
refusing to apologize for the fact that
we're in this position in the first
place and the public will say what are
the consequences who is responsible for
exposing taxpayers in this way do you
albeit as the newer chief executive of
the water regulator want to apologize on
behalf of your predecessors for ending
up in this position in the first place
so just in terms of I think it's very uh
we're beginning to be careful about the
parallel with energy sector and so as
I've explained energy companies which
failed had very little in the way of
assets we're talking about a in the
contempts case a 19 billion pound
company and so the question is can the
equity holders of needs must death
holders bear the consequences of Mr
Black a taxpayer and a customer is the
same person it's still a person paying
out money either to the government or to
a company my question was whether you
recognize the failure of the water
regulator over these many years that's
got us into this position in the first
place and whether now is the chief
executive of the water regulator much
like the chief executive of the energy
regulator did last year you want to
apologize for the public for the
position we're in today so we continue
to predict customers interest customers
that we are not in a position of either
teams being in special Administration uh
you think everything's okay right now is
that what you don't I think there's some
very serious issues that Thames water
need to address but my point is that
customers interests remain protected by
the regime we're not at the point uh
where it has been very clear that
customers are having to pay any more for
terms as Financial issues or for their
poor performance and that remains so and
as explained the situation energy is
different from water as in water
companies have much greater capacity to
absorb the consequences or should I say
they're shareholders I understand you've
made the promise of that just very
lastly because I'm going to be testing
the patients of the chair I'm very
patient person oh well thank you well
I'll keep going in that case
um do you therefore not have a request
of the government to enhance or extend
your powers because it seems to me that
both you Mr Black and your predecessor
Mr Ross in the previous panel have said
to us is up to the companies how they
run their businesses and don't worry
because if it goes wrong the
government's probably not going to have
to nationalize it anyway that's not what
it looks like from from where I'm
sitting so I would want you and the
other Regulators to be in a position
where when you're regulating a company
that is too important to fail you
actually know what's going on in that
business and you have the power to make
sure they don't end up in a position
like they're in now so do you need
additional powers from the government to
do that job properly so I agree that
this is your raising are very serious
and I agree that up until 2021 we didn't
feel weird social powers to address
those issues so the crucial change for
us in 2021 was our ability to amend
company licenses and so the licenses
instrument that we use to regulate
companies we now think we have
sufficient flexibility in terms of
amending licenses both in terms of the
changes we have already made but if we
think further changes are required to go
ahead and make those changes so we think
the government has now given us the
additional powers and we've also
received additional funding or the
ability to raise additional funding so
we can resource up to to exercise those
those new powers thank you thank you
Darren cat Smith thank you chair at Mr
Black earlier in response to a question
from my colleague Mr Jones there you did
say that the auto companies were in uh
transparent with yourselves as the
regulator but not necessarily with their
customers I'm just wondering I'm left
wondering what on Earth is the point of
a regulator if then you're not
communicating that with the public
so we think companies have a
responsibility to communicate clearly
with their customers and so that was the
question I was just I was responding to
we are able to get information from
companies we require them to provide
annual annual information address of
considerable detail we also have a five
yearly business plan where they set out
their five yearly projections I'm sorry
but if you know that companies are not
being transparent with their customers
and you know what's going on why why is
off what not communicating that with
them
we would we want companies to take
responsibility for communicating their
customers we've changed company licenses
to require them to to do that so we
think that they are now uh taking steps
to do that but the point I would make is
that it is challenging to explain these
issues to customers and I think quite
clearly customers do not feel bad
information and what is taking stuff
saturation so in terms of we can set
guidelines in terms of what companies
ought to be doing in terms of what they
publish lines are obviously optional
then yes we also have requirements of
what companies publish what are the
requirements so the companies do publish
annual financial statements they do set
out so the question is not so much they
set out the information it is about
communicating that in an understandable
form to their customers so we think why
the public are kind of questioning what
is the point
of your organization when it does appear
that you have done absolutely nothing to
inform them about some of the risks that
these companies are taking and I I am
left wondering whether or not this model
that we have of water ownership in this
country which is completely out of step
with what is probably the international
Norm here is is working because it
strikes me that in 2017 the Ft reported
in a 10-year review of Company accounts
that on profits of 20.7 billion pounds
water companies paid an average tax rate
of eight percent who benefits from water
privatization
uh so in terms of since privatization
190 billion pounds have been invested uh
uh so that and that has driven
significant improvements in service so
improvements in water quality uh
improvements reductions in in the levels
of pollution uh and improvements in uh
customer service reductions and water
supply interruptions so there's water
investment uh capital investment in the
sector was about double at the rate
pre-privatization so clearly the
question about the ownership of
companies as a matter of government not
for off watch uh but we you can point to
tangible Investments under the regulated
model of more investment uh and better
service uh that said we're under no
Illusions there are real problems for
the sector to address uh the situation
on sewage bills and storm overflows is
unacceptable uh now that we have the
information about those uh this charges
action has been taken but I should point
out that these are issues that exist in
other jurisdictions as well are there a
problem in Scotland they're a problem in
other countries as well it does require
a concerted effort to address it will
require more Investments and we're we're
part of that process we've had 34 years
of water privatization and why is it
that we're still talking about this
desperate need for investment if
privatization was meant to be the answer
to this investment question 34 years ago
why why are we still in this situation
today
because of the water companies uh so I
so in terms of areas of where companies
have fallen short of performance so
we've been very clear with the committee
that we think the performance of Thames
water is poor it needs to improve there
are other companies where we have
concerns about as well uh we think there
are sector-wide issues to address uh but
again as I point out if you look at
other countries other jurisdictions they
are facing the same challenges issues of
climate change high density urban areas
addressing uh uh particularly with older
infrastructure issues about making the
in terms of getting better performance
that in line with what the public would
expect and so that we can point to
significant investment since
privatization we can point to
significant improvements
of unpopular whenever we see public
polling on the idea of renationalization
of water companies it's incredibly
popular with the public why do you think
that is
I don't think that's a question for me
to answer I think you as a NP will be
much better place than me to address
English it's it's because of the
absolute failure of the water companies
in England right now
uh so to say we can point to huge
improvements and service huge levels of
Investments but clearly we accept the
public is dissatisfied with companies
we've done some research which suggests
that trust and companies have fallen
over the last uh three years uh we think
it's really important the sector address
those issues Ian and I called our
company's chairs and chief Executives in
to to really make the point that they
need to improve performance uh we are
seeing signs of change in the water
sector but much more change is needed
and this is not about who owns the
companies this is about companies uh
really adopting much more
forward-looking management practices so
investing in smart grid smart Network
should I say smart metering uh using
nature-based the solutions at scale uh
and really modernizing the way companies
work and we will continue to push the
sector to do just that can I just say a
couple of words
um it's a really good question about the
prioritized water model so it has been
privatized for 30 odd years 190 billion
pounds has gone into investment in the
sector that's four or five six billion
pounds a year I I would worry that in a
nationalized situation that the call on
that kind of investment wouldn't be
there so the money wouldn't be available
so it is going in why are we facing such
an investment crisis now it's because
the nature of investment is changing so
we've got to address things like water
resilience we now need more water to
cope with population growth urbanization
um climate change there's changing
standards on levels of water abstraction
but the rotations are pushing through
the drive towards net zero and the neat
address of stormwater overflow so that
is a very very significant step of
investment that we've not seen
in the past and that is causing some
concerns about the future
and my final question if I if I made
sure it's just about particularly like
Thames water and can I ask what plans
have been put in place to prepare Thames
water for potential failure and what
that might look like
uh so um what we call contingency
planning for the failure of a water
company something we keep under review
uh and in terms of our concerns about
Thames water we have been looking very
closely at the arrangements that need to
be taken and we are confident that we
can rise to the contingencies uh uh that
that may occur but we think it's prudent
planning to be ready for special
Administration uh but uh as the company
this morning they have sufficient
liquidity to meet the challenges of the
immediate future and shareholder
commitment for additional funding should
those materialize then obviously this
planning won't be needed but we think
it's prudent as a regulator that we
prepare for these outcomes and we've
been working on that would you say
you're confident that the special
Administration regime will not be needed
in the case of Thames water uh I think
uh we we need some rain ready to employ
that uh uh do you think you'll be
deploying it uh I think at this point in
time the company is saying that they
have secured commitments from their
shareholders and so believe them so it
won't be needed uh um obviously so so in
term terms of I think it's great that
the company have security from the
shareholders but clearly there is uh you
know the money has not yet arrived from
the company and so that at that point uh
we will feel uh more confident just just
add a little tiny bit one of the reasons
we're doing a lot of contingency
planning now is to learn the lessons of
bulb
um you know what that would mean it's
the most recent example of
administration so we're working with our
colleagues across government to say in
the unlikely circumstances it happens
I'll be ready have we got everything in
place so we don't think it's like at the
moment the reasons David said but it
will be sensible for everybody just to
think about the possible implications
you do not think it's likely
at this point in time we're confident
the shells will inject some cash but the
problems that attempt are deep rooted
and I start I re repeat what I said
before the problems that terms are a
function of cost overruns and poor
performance and they need to fix that as
quickly as possible otherwise
um they will have the same problems in
the future you being asleep at the wheel
as a regulator no
okay
sure thank you I think Dan wants to call
me very quickly very quick follow-up but
it's great to hear that you're trying to
learn the lessons from the bulb
um failure one of the issues with the
energy companies that collapsed last
year was the capital that the treasury
had to provide to keep the running as
going concerns bulb is was huge for the
energy Market but it's actually quite
small compared to Thames water what's
the assessment been for the treasury in
terms of the amount of capital it needs
to put aside should Thames water fail
uh so we've been working on those issues
I'm not going to name a number in terms
of in terms of where we're at in the
process but as I've noted there's quite
big differences between bulb which is an
relatively asset light company exposed
to energy Market fluctuations and Thames
which is a large Capital dates of
business uh with larger asset base and
ability to raise funding when the energy
market failure was happening both the
regulator and the government wrote to my
committee confidentially to tell us
those numbers were you commit to do that
to this committee
uh I think we probably refer that to
treasury these are questions for them
really okay thank you I think could you
sort of give taxpayers an assurance that
if there were to be a special
Administration this wouldn't be the
taxpayer bailing out the shareholders
they would have already lost their
shirts and it would be a case of picking
up the pieces more like the banks I
suspect than the the the energy
companies and that um who knows what you
know if the company performed well they
could well be sold back into the private
sector as we've seen with some of the
bank shares yeah so the company would
remain an attractive interest for other
potential investors and so as I say
they've got a 19 billion pound asset
base and they have a secure Revenue
stream uh so the question will be in
terms of the interest of existing
shareholders uh so they're the first in
terms of their equities at risk they're
well aware of that uh then there's a
question about the debt holders in the
company might be the same people we
heard in the first session uh I don't
think in the main that that is the case
okay thank you Barry
yes thank you chair
um first of all let me make it
absolutely clear I understand
Ian you came into the business only in
July last year and and Mr Black you came
in I think in April just before that so
um you you all are left
responding for things that happen
broadly before your UH your tenure and
and I just want to say we we appreciate
that
um
if we go back
let's go back to
um 2003.
South East water
and you'll remember that Macquarie
purchased Southeast water there
um they sold it three years later for
almost double what they purchased it for
and they had by that time increased the
debt more than four-fold
um
in effect they repeated that with Thames
water it was a much bigger Prospect
Thames water and they increased the debt
threefold there
and instead of it being the case that
companies raising debt in this way would
would
use it too
increase the infrastructure for the
benefit of the public the public good
they actually took 2.7 billion
out
of it and 2.2 billion of that within
loans
so you've rightly and that you've
reiterated it to this committee you
you've rightly said that you are we're
very concerned about the gearing not
only of of this company but but of
others in the sector
and the higher debt that gearing
gives a notional lower cost of capital
of financing doesn't it
um so lower charges then result in the
short term
um
but my accusation against offward would
be that you've basically over
you've encouraged
over leveraging
and I have to say the two of you are not
entirely innocent of this because of
course in August of last year after both
of you came into post and you encouraged
uh we purchased by Macquarie
um of Southern water
now you knew it's track record you know
what this company
you know it over leverages you know that
in the short term that can can get
charges down but when it goes wrong
and financing costs increase we see the
debacle that we've had
with Thames water
so
it seems to me that off what over a long
period of time
has been guilty of encouraging over
leveraging
and the immediate charge that I would
lay at your two doors
is that you did exactly the same thing
just after you came into post with
Southern water
so just in terms of to contextualize so
going back to around early 2000s so the
sector assets I forget actually go right
back to that of privatization the sector
asset base was nine billion pounds it
was fully financed by Equity at that
point today the sector asset base is
around 85 billion pounds and debt levels
around 57 billion pounds so that growth
and asset base of uh 78 77 billion
pounds into privatization 57 billion
pounds has been financed by debt and
about 20 billion from Equity so when we
look at the picture across the sector
debt has been a key source of Finance
not the only source of finance and that
was intended a privatization so that
debt levels would increase
over ground where we agree yes yeah so
now can I move on to the ground where we
just disagree so now moving on to the
the cases that you've talked through in
terms of um it's a very uh knowledgeable
question in terms of Southeast water and
the corresentative attempts uh I would
agree that macaro's ownership that they
uh you know they did differ companies
very high levels they extracted that and
form of dividends and that's the reasons
why we have changed the licenses want to
further power to to do so however we've
been very clear that about the new basis
and our new expectations of investors so
and just coming to the specifics of
Southern water macquarie's injected a
billion pounds into the southern water
group and now standing by to inject to
further 500 million pounds they have had
very little on the way of dividends out
of that company so I take something I
take some satisfaction and we've got new
controls on dividends now so they cannot
get the money out of the business uh if
so with the ability to intervene so I
take some satisfaction actually that
macquarie's as an investor are injecting
money into the sector rather than taking
it out of it and we have the
arrangements in place to protect
customers interests well it goes back to
um your response to to my colleague
Darren Jones doesn't it that that
actually what is this target about you
know the the gearing that you want and
if you can't enforce it
um what what gives you the assurance
that Macquarie are not going to do with
Southern water
exactly what they did with tens and
exactly what they did with Southeast can
I just say the difference is the new
Financial resilience measures we put in
place which prevent companies taking us
taking dividends out of the company when
they're poorly performing or when
they're not justified we didn't have
that power before sorry and
I I don't know the answer to this
question that's rare when I thought the
questions no no it's not I assure you
it's not Jeff
usually I know the answer to the
question that I'm asking so let me ask
you Mr Mr culture
um are you saying that in a highly
complicated debt structure like uh WBS
in in Thames water
that you have the power to stop
dividends going to each of those debt
Pairs and not only to what everybody
would normally understand as being the
shareholders the equity shareholders we
have the powers to stop dividends being
released from the operation company so
where they go beyond that is a matter of
the company but but we would the
financial powers that we have got retain
the dividends what would have been paid
inside the company if we're not
satisfied that they are performing and
they've not satisfied they have
sufficient Financial resilience we
didn't have that power before we do now
and the southern one is a good case in
point working so
certain um Macquarie have gone in there
with a group of investors they've looked
at the business they now realize and I
need to inject further Equity because of
the base and that is what they're doing
precisely now and we are confident that
the the situation that happened at uh a
decade or so ago is is now protected
thank you so what you're saying is had
had these new Arrangements been in place
uh when
our previous witness was the CEO of of
the organization and subsequently what
happened with off what happened with
tennis water it could have happened
we would have had the ability to block
the dividends going out of the company
yes uh so I think again it was a
question from my colleague Darren Jones
um to her
um when she denied that they had failed
in any way or lacked any parts to do so
that is one way in which the debacle
could have been presented prevented yeah
thank you
um so are you confident that going
forward
um no company no uh
part of the ownership of the company
would be able to receive the level of
returns that Macquarie was extracting
from
Thames water between 15.9 and 19
that's over double the normal uh return
that uh yeah
we've changed the license to to make
those um sorry to give us about to do
that but furthermore we've now got more
flexibility with the license if we think
further changes are required we will
introduce them right
um thank you very much
thank you I think Rosie wanted to come
over the supplementary on that yeah I
mean I'm going over some ground covered
by
do you understand why in the coastal
town of whitstable for example they
don't have a lot of faith in our all the
environment agency or anyone else that
is supposed to be imposing fines and
stopping you know we know that you
impose these record fines against
Southern water for example but nothing
is actually practically and physically
changed every time we get a thimble full
of rain there's sewage released into the
sea which affects every aspect of daily
life in a town like whitstable
um
can you just maybe you know can I just
give you the chance to kind of briefly
explain to them why they should have
faith in you what you can do I mean
you've talked about improving customer
service revoking licenses stopping
shareholders getting dividends
um and that customers interests remain
protected can you convince my
constituents that you're doing your job
I'm going to get this
um
so that the issue of stormwater
overflows
um
calling you know we have said this and I
have said this committee before
the Reliance over-reliance and use of
stormwater overflows to deal with
rainfall as you suggest is is
unacceptable
so what we have we've been very clear to
everybody that if a company and this is
the same for the environmental agency if
a company is in breach of its legal or
regular obligations they will take
action and they will force compliance
and the companies will be responsible
for rectifying the problems
we have got ourselves in a situation
where some of these stormwater overflows
have do allow underpermits
to release sewage into the underwater
systems we need to tighten up all of
those permits to say to people that is
no longer acceptable so you might have a
permit today but we need to see that
tightened over the course of time but
you know we will enforce and ensure
companies comply with the law compile
with their environmental obligations and
their permitting requirements and the
cost of doing so is for the companies
themselves we have got six
concurrent large-scale investigations
into the companies that have been doing
this to satisfy ourselves but they are
complying with legal obligations and
comply with environmental permits they
are complicated I don't wish to
trivialize it but we are working through
that and we know our colleagues at the
EA doing exactly the same
frankly if they're still within those
legal limits though and sewage is still
spilling out every time it rains who is
then responsible for changing that or
imposing different legal limits or I
mean is that us so you're saying we need
to come back and change that or
definitely to that's a different
environment agency so it's the
environment agency that permits each and
every storm discharge and so that's the
that's the arrangement can we just just
refer to the um
death was water plan for water which
does set much lower targets the use of
these storm water flows it's going to
take time but it's uh the government has
said at a 56 billion pound plan to
address this issue I've been on site at
whitstable so there is scope to make
quick improvements which the companies
in the process of making but then there
are some quite significant issues which
will require investment to address
you've been before us before and I've
asked you about the the teeth that you
have in terms of putting pressure on the
water companies and we've talked about
fines and then not allowing dividends to
go out
um in terms we've talked about financial
performance today
um and we and and Rosie's been touching
on the sort of sewage outflows as well
do you feel that the teeth you have
um if water companies are having these
unacceptable and immoral sewage
discharges into our watercourses do you
feel that you have the teeth and what
are those teeth would they be with the
fines or can you potentially stop the
dividends going out if they are
breaching the sewage outflows as well or
is it more financial performance that
you're going to be using that particular
tooth um particularly I'll stay over to
us today but I would just say that yes
we have got the power to enforce
compliance
um to address any aspect of
underperformance through either find
withholding dividend payments if we
think they are in breach of their
obligations it's the underperformance it
could be about sewage rather than
financial underperformance yes yes okay
so we have a set of performance
equations we also have obligations that
we enforce on companies in terms of the
operation of their sewage systems and so
that's what we're investigating with our
six cases uh we will have the ability to
impose Financial penalties we've imposed
250 million pounds of penalties on
companies in the last five years we
won't hesitate to use those Powers I
reassure the committee and the public
watching this you will use those teeth
to hold those water companies to account
and I just said one actually when I did
a paper view before
uh when I've heard you before you're
asking it's very similar questions so in
the last 12 months what we have done
we've secured additional funding uh from
treasury into defra to allow us to ramp
up our investigation capabilities that
we are in empowering our people to be
much much more intrusive on companies
performance so it's a more muscular
approach that when we see companies not
performing below election we have had
them in and we've said we would like a
rectification platform you your
performance is not acceptable please
give us a turn around plan to rectifying
that is new we didn't do that before and
uh in the first part of this year we had
five companies in to say we are not
satisfied please give us an improvement
program and that's a result of the extra
powers that we've we've secured in extra
funds sorry data because of course yeah
so we you know we think we do have the
powers I mean as noted there's there is
the Royal environment agency in terms of
setting permits at sites but we have the
powers with the ability to to impose
large Financial penalties up to 10
percent of turnover on we've got the
powers can you just reassure us and the
public that you will use this house
we're we're taking we're taking
enforcement actually get six large
Wastewater companies at present uh and I
know these investigations do take time
and people are impatient to see results
I am as well uh but we are making good
progress uh and we will have
announcements to cover that I wanted to
move back on to the the topic that we
touched on earlier today in terms of
Staffing and Leadership and and the
relationship between the the regulator
and the sector and we've we know that
one of our previous Witnesses the uh um
the new interim Chief joint The Joint
chief executive Thames water was
formerly one of your predecessors uh Mr
Black at off what
um do you feel that the other high
numbers of of senior off-what staff
moving to potentially higher paid
positions in private water companies do
you feel that that is problematic at all
for your ability to main trust in off
worlds off what's role and motives so
firstly just to reassure we do all
departure small forward are covered by
civil service business appointment rules
uh which does do allow us to impose
conditions on staff for up to two years
after they leave in terms of the work
they're undertake uh and how they uh so
that's important I think the point I'd
make is in terms of contextualizing this
where there's been lots of media reports
on this issue but they're talking about
numbers which amount to two or three
staff members per year leaving our
organization over 300 people at each one
of the and a number of those members
didn't go from off to Water Country they
went off what to another employer to a
water company you mentioned these media
reports you recognize the figures of
about 27 former off-what directors
managers and Consultants who are now
currently working with private water
companies do you recognize those figures
recognizes figures but the point I
wouldn't make is that a number of those
people left off what to go to work you
know even another sector or not for a
water company and then later on some
years later have gone to work for a
water company and so I think it does
need to be seen in that context we do
have strict rules about what people do
upon leaving off what uh and so you know
I think these numbers are you know do
not support any kind of uh the
contention that that's been made we
recognize that in the public sector
there are finite resources in terms of
the salaries that can be paid and we
understand that
um Professor sadita Helm at Oxford
University has said there is a
merry-go-round between the core
regulators and the regulated utilities
Regulators are not paid well and if
there is a potential of future jobs and
the firms they regulate it creates
potential conflicts of interest
do you concur with that statement at all
uh I you know I don't accept I mean I
work with an incredible bunch of very
dedicated people um as I say most of
whom do not go to work for water
companies uh so they uh so so I think
they do a fantastic job uh they're very
dedicated to to the public interest to
protecting customers interests and it's
probably worth noting that Professor
Helm also works for these water
companies and as engagements so
Point
um and and I do very much take on board
what you say that that the people that
work for your organization work so hard
to try and do the best to to improve the
water quality for our country but for
you as two leaders of that regulator
does it concern you that potential tool
and drag into the private sector that it
is draining you of the vital resource
that you need to do the best job that
you can going to contextualize that I
think only one member of senior
leadership team which is Catherine Ross
you've seen earlier has left or thought
to end she didn't go to water companies
she went to BT but has also ended up in
a water company so uh it doesn't worry
you then so no I think I I think people
it doesn't look good I accept that
um but you know I'd like to assure the
committee to anybody
you know we have
um processes and governance regimes to
make sure that decisions are are
syndicated they're taken thoughtfully
and considering that no one individual
really has the powers to make decisions
which uh may be biased or whatever it
may be so I'm I'm reasonably reassured
that the decision-making process we've
got
protects that but I do accept that on
the face of it people could ask
questions but for David's reasons it's
it it's not really an issue there's a
small number of people they tend to be
more Junior people and they tend to end
up in the regulatory Departments of
these big organizations which tends to
be a bit of a specialist skill so
understandably they've got skills
knowledge and capabilities about the
process which is available for companies
but I do accept your your observation
thank you
I'm just following that at that point up
just for the avoidance of doubt and for
clarity and reassuring the public can
you confirm that uh you in have no
financial interest in a water company or
a company which is a major supplier to a
water company I have got no interest at
all in any water company any supply to
the water industry thank you and David
can you give us the same reassurance yes
that's right I have no interest in any
water company thank you and for anybody
you bring into the company but whether
an executive or non-executive into
offerups when I run the company you
receive a similar Assurance yes yeah
it's very clear upon entering employment
at off what you're not allowed to own
shares in order company
thank you David you talked about
obviously your producer Financial
monitoring report which uh delves into
some of the way these
um companies are funny but you also said
that sometimes they were fairly opaque
mechanisms
do you think having more powers to sort
of delve into some of these opaque
funding streams would up you or do you
feel you've got enough Powers at the
moment I think we have adequate powers
to require information from companies
and there is a question about level
resources and expertise required and so
we are looking to and beef up our
resources in that space and so I guess
my my key question is you know do we
have the the resources in that space and
that's why I'm pleased we've got the
additional funding to strengthen our
capabilities but it is a you know it is
a it is a complex area it's an area of
specialist expertise as it's not just
about having the information it's about
having the expertise to understand
what's going on to ask the right
questions to companies and just
following on from um Neil's point you
said only one person has moved from off
what to I think figure whistle is 27 so
I said one member of the senior
leadership team which is Catherine Ross
so the 27 people are referred to and
pretty soon the period of time I think
is about three to three employees a year
we'd have that figured before
um sorry chair that I don't think that's
accurate either six of the nine uh
companies in England have hire directors
of corporate strategy or heads of
Regulation who previously worked on what
um Andrew beaver
northumbrian water former director
strategy and planning Ian mcguffic at
Southern water
um Roth at thameswater Jonathan Reed
director of regulatory policy there's a
none of those were members of our fought
senior leadership team just to be clear
did you have senior leadership positions
of senior positions within their company
within the companies that they've joined
uh half of the 27 have gone on to senior
leadership positions in the companies
water off what they weren't a member of
the leadership team where they were
lower down the higher
okay we're bang on the time I had in the
back of my mind for moving on to the
final evidence session so thank you very
much indeed and thank you David for
coming and giving us such useful
evidence thank you very much
apparently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
foreign
the proceeding is currently suspected
well thank you and um Welcome to our
panel for the second session uh if that
could ask you to introduce yourself
starting with the minister I think
good morning sir
um Rebecca Powell our environment
Minister uh also water Minister comes
under my portfolio
I'm David Hill I'm the director general
for the environment in defra perfect
thank you in fact a start minister with
the question we heard how you know in
the worst scenario if there was a
failure you know we've been looking at
some of the energy companies the banks
if there was a failure and the water
companies have to go into special
Administration
How concerned you are you about the
potential failure at Thames water and
other providers in the sector is it on
your radar
well as the water Minister obviously uh
I'm looking at all the water companies
and working very closely
um to make sure offworks are doing their
job as the regulator so they would be
highlighting things to us constantly of
course and we were very mindful of their
resilience report they came out with
earlier in the year in terms of the
special Administration order that you're
referring to of course
should a water company no longer be able
to fulfill its financial obligations and
Secretary of State and all four have got
powers to apply for this on insolvency
grounds but uh I've been made fully
aware and in fact the new chairman of
Sir Adrian came in to see the Secretary
of State uh just yesterday who gave
absolute assurances that we are nowhere
near that that situation but a
government would always have to have the
measures in place should they ever be
required would you agree that they've
been skating on dangerously thin ice
with eight percent gearing and half
their debt linked to inflation with
inflation Rising I mean obviously that
they there's been alarm bells ringing
all around not just terms of water but
other water companies also highly geared
and so exposed to debt repayments well
obvious we look really closely at this
whole issue of depth and gearing and how
the whole system works in terms of
attracting outside funding
in terms of equity or raising debt
because obviously the water companies
have got to pay for all of the
investment the huge investment in
infrastructure and let's not forget that
since privatization investment has
actually doubled compared to what it was
before privatization and it's attracted
in 190 billion pounds well it's just
twos or maybe yeah money which um
you know what one might say would we
would have struggled to have attracted
uh had we not gone through this process
of privatization because if you talk to
people we might call it back in the old
days Roberts I think you and I were
around and I've I met with a whole lot
of people actually
um who who um were involved
pre-privatization and then saw the
system through and now privatization to
for them to reflect on their thoughts on
it you know and the water system was in
a terrible State you know we did have
terrible leakage we did we have had
masses of interruptions to supply
um and we cut leakage by I think a third
we cut Supply
outages by a fit you know so there's
been huge
um improvements so I honestly think we
must not forget to tell that story
that's not to say there is not an awful
lot we have to keep our eye on and we
have to make sure our water companies
are delivering what we need now you know
and also a changing world I think the um
the chair before referred to that we got
huge demands on us and that because also
climate change and so forth but the in
terms of the I think you asked the
question about the gearing uh well
um
uh obviously off what did indicate in
their financial resilience report that
they had some concerns about tens that's
why
um you know they're working with them
very very closely but I think and I'd
like to draw the committee's attention
to those statements that we've had from
or Fort and Thames water so on the 29th
of June we had a statement that
emphasized that terms water had a strong
liquidity position which included 4.4
billion pounds of cash and committed
funding and we just had the Thames water
announcement haven't we this week with
the accounts via the annual report that
they've secured a further that was and
that some money was was committed
earlier in the year but we've had a
further 750 million pounds of equity
well that was a shortfall on the billion
that was suggested needed to be injected
though wasn't it yeah but I think they
gave some adequate answers I've been
listening to you know this is the money
that needs be spent soon soon and they
need to know that they got it and the
company
um is uh is is knows that little
shareholders know that they'll be
seeking another 2.5 billion pounds and
they've given a statement of intent of
that and actually you asked about the
gearing so with this injection of funds
it's just dropped to 77.4 so it's coming
down
um
I have to um I have to just get this in
there chairman that it was actually
under the labor party uh in the sort of
mid-2000s that this debt if you look at
a graph started to go like this in the
water companies uh and it's stabilized
under this government what we've been
talking about today is the difference
between
um raising debt to pay dividends and
raising debt to invest in infrastructure
which are two completely different
things yeah well I think you've had a
lot of discussion and answers about that
and about about you know where the money
goes but equally
um
terms haven't paid what they call
dividends for six years but they
completely admitted in their accounts
um that
um the shareholders haven't been paid
the dividends but the money has gone to
that um that service holding committee
and I'll bring David in here if you want
more detail on that
I think the question I was going to ask
maybe David could could call me if
Nessie you know are you prepared for
potential failure and if so could you
reassure the committee and indeed the
taxpayers that this wouldn't be about
bailing out the shareholders but about
ensuring that service continues to be
supplied oh absolutely I think that's a
really clear message we have to give
customers uh this will not affect
customers the whole point if it was ever
needed uh would be and it's not a form
of renationalization just to get that
Athlete on the record it's actually it's
a tool that's used to ensure that the
services can continue and that new
owners can be found
um bulb has been referred to a number of
times in the work with designers so
um you know lessons can be learned from
that obviously water companies are
different in the way they're structured
but we can give absolute assurances that
if necessary uh the system is there but
also I'd really like to assure the
committee that we will keep the
community T informed as and when and if
necessary but as I said in speaking to
the chairman yesterday we we would be
it's not it's not on the cards we're a
long way from that there's a lot of work
underway already returns uh to to sort
the gearing out and to ensure that um
the company can continue to deliver the
services customers need
just add a little to that uh chair so as
the minister said should a special
Administration order ever be needed
um for a water company the the statutory
purpose of the order uh would be to
ensure that customers continue to
receive their water and their Wastewater
services and that's that's
um that public interest test is really
the reason we have a special
Administration regime on the statute
book in the in the 1991 water industry
as I think um David black was saying
earlier
um uh in terms of taxpayer liabilities
uh important to to note that this is a
company in the case of Thames with 19
billion pounds worth of assets so in the
first instance the task of the
administrator if appointed would be to
work with uh uh debt holders and the
company uh to protect the interests of
the taxpayer on your question about
preparedness obviously we need to keep
all of our preparations for a whole
range of scenarios up to date and that's
what that's what we will do
um but as I think um sir Adrian
indicated earlier the liquidity
statement from the company was important
because I think that's the company very
clearly signaling that with 4.4 billion
pounds of liquidity
was some way off some of these more uh
some of these more
uh some of these scenarios okay thank
you Julian story yeah thank you chair
um I just wanted to minister I just
wanted to touch on worst case scenarios
I've already you've already mentioned
that you've we're some way off this
um which is good news but if it was a
worst case scenario how advanced are
plans to potentially nationalize Thames
water and have you estimated any costs
of doing that
well reiterate we know we're near that
and what we don't want to do is is you
know scare people
we this is being closely modested by
times they're working incredibly closely
uh with um off what uh to steer through
this uh and and also it's not
rationalization I think you
you said that
um and and government has the process
you know it has the powers if they're
needed uh and won't hesitate to use them
of course
um and so I think you know I need to
give assurances that that is what would
happen
um you know we've got and what you know
government the Secretary of State and of
what have the powers to
um to place a company in
special Administration effectively
and the point of it would be that it so
that it could be transferred as a going
concern to new owners uh and
um either on insolvency grounds uh
because they weren't able to pay their
debts or the other way it would happen
would be if it was um on enforcement
grounds if they were into a serious
breach of
um of one of their duties I understand
all that and I understand that this is
I'm talking about worst case scenario
but it's just really what planning has
been done if this scenario does come up
and also what ability is it to put would
it be to pass it on to a another another
buyer basically and have you looked at
those options
um going forward and I suppose also what
conversations have you had with treasury
about this as well
so um as I say we keep all our
preparations up to date for a range of
scenarios up to and including special
Administration should there ever be
required and say it doesn't look uh it
doesn't look uh imminent at this point
in time as I think both the company and
the regulator said earlier we would do
all of that work uh jointly with the
treasury and indeed with um ukgi
um as well
um uh and so should it be required
um we would be prepared for that
um that said
um the company has just signed off its
accounts and it's returned its various
statements to off what uh giving
Assurance the Judgment of the directors
that it's a going concern uh
independently validated by the Auditors
um the focus now is on the company's
business plan that's the critical thing
that The Regulators need to see is the
company bring forward its business plan
I think you did some sir Adrian Montague
talking about this earlier the company
does need to prioritize as part of its
business plan
um there are performance issues the
company needs to address and that's the
thing I think our principle focuses on
for the foreseeable okay but I still
haven't really you still haven't you
stop giving me the confidence that in
this worst case scenario that those
those plans are there in the background
ready to go
you can you confirm that we have all we
keep all of our preparations up to date
up to and including preparations for a
special Administration order should we
ever need to to apply to the court for
one okay thank you last point if I can
share very quickly
um in the some of the previous uh
discussion um in terms of water it was
discussed about Thames water having a an
immediate uh payoff of around uh 560
million of their debt in case of a
nationalization
um now they say they don't recognize
that cause I don't have you could you
put shed any light on that stool we saw
that earlier exchange I'm afraid we
didn't recognize the figure either so we
will do a bit of um we'll check in with
the regulator and indeed with the
company after this committee and I think
um the committee committed to right on
that point uh the company commit to
write on that point yeah could you share
that information with us when you of
course thank you okay thank you very
much thank you thanks Jay England Wales
International outliers on the level of
water industry
advertisation since 1989.
privatization since 1989 to give us 72
billion pounds gone to shareholders
water companies are built up at that
mountain of 60 billion use this to
finance dividends to shareholders our
bills have gone up 40 in real time teams
since prioritization the environmental
agency is set by 2050 some Rivers will
see 50 to 80 percent less water during
the summer months because of the uh
climate disaster
water companies are now actually leaking
away 2.4 billion liters of water every
day every day the Water Company's
discharge we're all sewage into our
rivers and seas over 9 million hours
since 2016 and we know the consequences
of that
catastrophically 14
of English rivers are considered to have
good ecological status not one reservoir
has been built since 1989.
and nearly 70 percent of the British
public want water back into public
ownership
so would you not agree with the vast
majority the British public the
experiments of privatization is
certainly not saved the best interest in
this country at Large
thank you for your list sir
um I just want to put something on the
record chair actually if you take
inflation into account since 2020 uh our
water bills have been pretty static 2020
20 2010 sorry 2010
2010 to 11. it was uh 427 pounds on
average and 2020 to 21 it would be
426 pounds so I think we had to uh look
at that in perspective and take
inflation into account so I think your
main question was about privatization
though yes
um and I would uh reiterate that and
actually
um you know England is relatively
unusual in terms of its privatization
model compared to other countries
um but actually the UK invests small per
inhabitant than most of our comparable
countries and that does include Germany
and France
and actually we've had increased levels
of investment since privatization as I
said at the beginning
um which has results
and this is an ideological this is this
is a lot of conservative vultures in the
same mindsets widely so unhappy with the
current system why do they want it to
bring back into public ownership in in
terms of
um any uh just um you know errors that
water companies have made I've made it
absolutely clear many many times
standing at the dispatch books that they
need to be held to account for example
whether it's the uh use of their storm
sewage overflows way above what their
permits allow that's why we brought from
the storm sewage overflow reduction plan
that's why we've asked every single
company to produce the plan for all of
their store the relevant storm surgery
because they are now with our department
they have already come in but I think
you know it has to be said since
privatization we've attracted 190
billion pounds that's about 5 billion a
year which arguably would have been very
very
old levels of this satisfaction
why so many people so angry about what's
happening we want satisfaction as well
don't we and and I think we also and I
would be the first to say all the
companies have to get in their house in
order and that's why we're coming down
so hard on them but also why we have put
so much in the environment act while
we've got our integrated plan for water
why we had our storm sewage overflows
reduction plan and while you've got all
our targets that they're going to have
to deliver on but I think
we do also have to say that um
we've had some successes under
privatization leakage has been cut by a
third outages have been cut by fit and
I'm not defending any of the recent
outages we've had from some water
companies they have to get their house
in order and and they are and that's
what off what has to do and that's what
we have to oversee and I think we have
to demonstrate to the public that a lot
of good is being done for water and
water is the most critical thing going
forward that's why we brought out our
integrated plan for water and why is the
government we have actually we're
backing it all up with legislation and
indeed enforcement and higher penalties
and so forth maybe we have to seek the
ideological Steve Jeffer alternative
models of ownership because many would
save being a catastrophic decision to to
leave a public board in the at the mercy
of the markets
sustains life so we looked at
alternative models of ownership and
governments such as dollars in the Welsh
Scottish and Northern Irish Waters well
well obviously it's really sensible to
learn from other people but in terms of
um
Auckland I think David will back me here
up here so in our in England we're now
monitoring and it's this government
that's brought in all the monitoring
that's why we really know what's
happening this happened under the
conservative government not the previous
labor government I think it was four
percent of storm surge overflow's
monitoring when we took over now it's 93
and it will be 100 by the end of the
year now in Scotland uh they actually
only monitor four percent of their storm
surge overflows and in Wales I believe
I'm right and we can send you the stats
chair uh their
illegal use basically of storm sewage
overflows is much higher than it is in
England I think David you might be able
to back down into a quite an ideological
debate which you know this particular
looking at the issue of Thames water the
problems they face at the moment so I
understand that I think probably the
next general election will be a good
opportunity to exercise as issues
yeah
so okay so if we move on to uh Derek
Thomas
thank you very much
um so actually I'm sadly picking up from
that and it is you're right about the
monitoring the reason people might be
dissatisfied is because actually we have
provided some very transparent
information about what's actually going
on and then how we fix it I completely
get that we've engaged with the
consumers told them customers told them
what uh is expected and that's why
they're um much more aware what's going
on but the concern I've got is that much
of the water industry is owned by
oversea Financial investors I wonder if
you think uh with that responsibility in
your portfolio portfolio whether
actually that's a an acceptable thing to
have for the UK
customer and whether they should be
strict to ownership criteria
um yes thank you thank you for um for
that and yes we we do have a lot of
overseas investment but I think in a way
that's one of the strengths of the
system despite all of the conversations
that have been going on we've still
continued to attract a great deal of
overseas investment and we need to
attract in overseas investment uh
so that we've got the funding that we
require obviously
um a strict eye needs to be kept on uh
on that and where it's where it is
coming from
um and but we do actually uh just to
give reassurances we do have a power to
intervene
um in Investments uh through the
um National Security investment Act
and indeed we would have the power to
block an investment if it was deemed
necessary David might want to add to
that that's certainly true on uh
National Security grounds under the ACT
to be familiar to Mr Jones uh I think I
think the other point to make in terms
of
um uh foreign investment is there's no
differentiation in terms of of what's
ability to regulate and take enforcement
action whether the investor is a
domestic investor or an overseas
investor so oft will regulate as it were
sort of blind to the provenance of the
the investment and we'll go through a
process of of testing
in dialogue with prospective investors
any Acquisitions yeah thanks um so we
had a lot of them how much you caught of
the role of Macquarie earlier on in the
session and given the issues caused by
macquarie's ownership of Thames water
should we have concerns about the
ownership of Southern water and other
Centrum structure such as Gas
Distribution infrastructure in the UK by
that company
um yes I did I overheard a bit we were
just waiting outside the door at that
bit but
um you know I suppose I suppose we you
know I would reiterate that we are still
continuing to attract this overseas
Capital which we really need
um and we do have the powers you know to
intervene if necessary
um and
um and there's been very close oversight
of Macquarie and its involvement with
Southern uh Southern itself you know
it's it's actually doing uh the right
the sort of self-monitoring it actually
needs to do it's just put a stop on
paying out any dividends as a result of
one of the recent credit ratings that
didn't come from what that didn't come
from us you know they did their boards
did that themselves
um and
um
and you know if and if there were
concerns this is why offwatch had got
this very clear oversight why they've
really ramped up their
um monitoring uh and their um their
assessments of financial resilience uh
and why we put new powers in the
environment act you know which they
wanted uh so that they can change
licenses and in fact uh what happened
with that change over at Southern of
course was there was an opportunity with
a new company coming in to change the
license uh so uh so that they can
uh get these resilience measures firmly
embedded and for example you know
dividends now cannot be paid if there's
any issue about financial and the credit
rating or environmental performance and
in fact that all backs up what we said
to you or for in our strategic policy
statements which we give to all for and
they have to act in accordance with it
so if I may just just briefly build on
that answer I mean I think the important
change that the environment act brought
in is that whilst previously off what
occurred very licensed conditions it had
to be done with the agreement of the
company and what the ACT does is it
strengthens it so off what can now
impose licensed conditions on the
company and to other and two other first
uses of those powers are one as I think
of what we're explaining earlier
um preventing money flowing out of the
regulated company and circumstances
where the credit rating of the regulated
company is reduced and two much more
explicit enforcement of a linkage
between dividend payment and input and
performance and so that's that is a
distinct shift with more legal backing
for off what compared to when Macquarie
first entered the sector and also
um a treasury of just agreed that of
what
um I've basically got another 11.3
million pounds for enforcement so that's
going to go on more monitoring or
reporting this you know much uh much
more forensic oversight well thankfully
for that concept thank you very much um
I I think your office indicates you need
to work half past 12 but if you're not
catching a train could we Prevail upon
you for a little bit longer I mean
obviously I'm sorry
11. sorry half a cylinder can we Prevail
upon you feel we will we will we'll do
our best to a short answers would
probably help in that regard as well
Darren just a short question for me on
that on that basis the UK is about to
join the comprehensive and Progressive
trans-pacific partnership cptpp
um where companies from those member
countries can sue the British government
in a private Interstate dispute
settlement scheme for loss of expected
earnings because of the actions of the
British government Canada and Australia
are both members of cptpp if we end up
in an environment where the government
has to take action on Thames water for
example and the Canadian shareholder
loses out could they bring action
against the British government to
recover that amount and has that legal
risk assessment being done as part of
your planning
well let me I think I should take it
away and give you a fuller response but
of course the decision for the decision
to enter an Administration and let's
rest with the court so the government
the Secretary of State or off what with
the consent of the secretary state would
apply to the court so in those
circumstances it would be the court
making Administration order so I will
talk to my lawyers but um in effect they
would be seeking to bring action against
a a court order you could write to us
with your assessment that would be
helpful happy to know the answer which
is why I'm asking but yes I think some
lawyers could get quite rich on this
particular Point Marriott following up
on the issue of uh foreign investors
yesterday the Deputy Prime Minister
identified China as the top security
concern now you have uh said today that
it's a good thing that we have foreign
investors in our intense water but of
course the Chinese Investment
corporation earns 8.7 percent
of that do you think that that's a good
thing or is it something that the Deputy
Prime Minister should be concerned about
I'll just refer you back to my previous
answer if there were any concerns
um that there are powers to intervene to
block investment and we do have the
National Security investment act and we
you know could act accordingly with that
so unless David wants to say anymore I
think I'll leave it at that I don't
think there's any more we can say here
about that no
thank you Neil Hudson thank you chair
um today we've been looking at the the
example of Thames water but also as its
broader implications for the resilience
of the the water sector across the
country now the government has said that
that through what's going on with Thames
there is no risk of water bills going up
but given that huge infrastructure
investment is required do you feel that
that position can hold can you reassure
the public that that bills will not be
affected
well as he will know bills are capped
until 2025 anyway uh there's no
expectation that bills will be rising in
the short term they actually are subject
to inflation that's completely separate
from what's Happening to the uh water
companies but in terms of any potential
um Rises to to bills that will all come
out in the wash once uh off what have
gone through all of the the business
plans for the water companies so
um and and you know you know how they
work they look at what uh water
companies are required to deliver or
expectations with a government have put
on them through our targets and through
the Public's expectations In fairness uh
the huge investment that we'll have have
to happen in future
um and uh and then uh
decisions will be made but I would
really add that we're always mindful of
the effect on consumers we do have a
sound system for
um looking after the vulnerable and we
have our watershaw system I think
already 1.3 million people have been
helped through that so that is always
there that our social tariffs uh payment
holidays and so forth and will continue
to be there
um and uh and indeed you know we will we
will consider considerations will be
made about whether there might be some
um impact on customer Mills but we can't
say what that will be yet broadly you
feel that hopefully the the five yearly
water build review the these events
shouldn't Buffet them too significantly
well also the whole reason why we have
the debt and the equity of course is to
get the big cash injection into build
the infrastructure as fast as we can uh
within the limits of you know have you
got the people of Ables build the stuff
uh in particular uh have we got the
materials but also so you don't get
sudden impacts on Bill payers and it's
always got to be smoothed out I mean I I
I I think it wouldn't be wrong to say
that of course Thames tied away tunnel
you know that has been factored into
bills that was all completely understood
by the people of London and I think
that's due to open next year
um and that's the way that's worked and
that's a completely separate private
partnership and private public
partnership separates of that the
government's announced a very welcome
that that there will be a potentially
unlimited fines on water companies that
don't
um play according to the rules and and
and and and not fulfilling their their
capabilities can you give reassurances
that if those fines are enacted and we
welcome that those teeth are now being
given to the regulators and the
enforcing agencies can you give
reassurance to the public that that will
not have any effect on on water bills
with the fines if if we no well the
fines have got to come out of you know
from shareholders then no money should
ever come from customers to pay for
these um fines they should have no
effect on customers and uh you know we
we've also
um set up our water restoration fund so
that money from fines go into that that
money will go back into the environment
and uh you know we I think you are
referring to our announcement that we
just made about the um variable monetary
um penalties
um shall I talk about that now chair if
you want to briefly give it a plug it
very exciting coincidental it was
announced just before this well you know
chair that we've been working on this
and indeed um Mr the rice honorable uh
Philip Dunn has has worked very hard on
this particular issue uh as have many
others to see if we could the common
current limits you know on the cap for
um civil penalty penalties is 250 000
pounds uh today we've announced that
will be unlimited and
um that's for uh people contributing
their permits and it's you know it will
be used as and when appropriate but you
can still there will still be obviously
criminal opportunity to go to the
criminal court but if appropriate these
civil penalties can be used
I'm getting Alan wanted to come in
briefly on the back of that question
yeah thanks share um I should say I work
for Scottish water so just a bit like an
record of the months to referred to
Scottish water and about private
investment being the way forward but
it's worth pointing out Scottish Waters
invested 35 more per head on average
since privatization compared to England
and the Bowser law office of investment
can be done through the public body but
just as Minister do you believe in the
political Place principle
in the polluter pays principle yes yeah
and I think I would take issue
potentially on some of the Scottish
stats so I think chair we need to just
look at those because uh I did give this
statue yeah
but so for me I'm I'm very quiet
if we move on yeah
um and Ingrid in Wales are still all
right to connect 12 housing developers
last year something like 200 out 200 000
houses were built in England Wales
connected to sewer system if they cause
any overloading of research system cause
any additional overflow discharges then
it falls in the water company and the
bill payers top grade the sewers so in
effect that's not that that's the
opposite of the political Place
principle what are Bill pairs in England
Wales are paying a subsidy their housing
developers because Normal practice would
be housing developers have to pay for
upgrades for the sewer before the houses
are constructed so why is the government
not changing I would refer him to
integrated plan for water where we cover
this specifically in terms of all new
houses
separate connections and I would also uh
refer to the work we're doing with the
Dulux department and the Housing
Industry uh to separate out these
systems it's not well yet it's okay it's
starting to practice yet
uh well in many new developments already
do it uh but you know going online this
will be what will happen and your
housing developer can come along connect
5 000 houses to the sewer and it's not
mandatory to do a sustain award-winning
drainage and it's not mandated for them
to do it
when it will be and we will give you
chapter and verse chairman uh
subsidizing housing developers isn't
that the case uh no I've answered the
question we you know this is being
addressed uh we got you know hundreds of
thousands of Victorian houses in this
country uh and that's one of the
problems uh that's why we have storms
overflows is because of this system and
that they had to be an extra emergency
Fail-Safe measure we're addressing all
this now
um
of course it's the existing housing
stock that caused problem with
stormwater outflows new housing has
separate hot Waters so exactly juices
inundated system right and we're also
putting in sustainable Urban drainage
which will also address the pollen here
dressing last question so just following
up uh Neil Hudson's comments about the
regulator and the licensing regime
um we've we heard from offwa earlier uh
that they are part of the investing they
are investigating Thames water permit
breaches alongside the environment
agency over 2 000 of them that was
something that was initiated in response
to a report from the environmental audit
committee on the one hand and the new
office Environmental Protection focused
on water issues it was not stimulated by
their own action and recognition of
problems do you believe that the powers
that they've now got that you've just
been referring to and the actual
resource you've just been referring to
will allow their armed agency and off
what to do their job properly and
investigate permanent
as a matter of routine course rather
than property to do so parliamentary and
other interaction well obviously we want
them to be fully functioning enforcing
we want clean water I said all the way
along the line that you know sewage in
rivers is unacceptable uh uh you know
some of the stats we've had for water
companies are unacceptable and that's
why we've been tightening step by step
by step uh The Regulators Powers uh why
we brought forward those measures in the
environment act uh which will enable
licenses to be
um much more altered uh so that
dividends cannot be paid out if there's
any environmental damage or if there's a
financial
um issue with the credit rating but it's
also why
um off what have now got this extra 11.3
million on the enforcements it's why
we've introduced these variable monetary
penalties that are uncapped and it's
also In fairness it's because of the
monitoring where living as a government
that all of this has actually come to
light I know that the EAC did a lot of
really useful work if I'm honest and
this Committee in you know in in helping
gather the evidence for lots of these
things but it's the monitoring that's
bringing it all to light and it was
actually our monitoring that showed that
lots of these water companies were
breaching their permits and actually
some of them they did put their hands up
and say we admit we are using our storms
which overflows too much and that's
through them we've got this huge
investigation that's been underway and
we're wading through all of those and
people will be taken hell to account you
know if they are responsible so the
outcomes from those investigations will
be subject to this now new as we've just
said uncapped filing regimes people with
permits that that comes under the
permitting regime but they but they
could there are two courses the Civil
penalties which will be quicker uh to
operate but there is still the recourse
to go to the court if I might yeah the
um the EA investigation into
um potential permit breaches at
wastewater treatment works is a criminal
investigation so wouldn't be subject to
today's announcement which is
um essentially giving them more uh more
Tools in relation to civil sanctions but
for the most egregious uh uh cases uh
there's still the criminal route and
that's that's the route they've gone
there the Civil sanction can be applied
for by the environment agency
environmental regulators and that would
apply for example where a campaign group
identified a problem drew it to the
attention of either National environment
agency and then instead of being treated
as a routine expense of doing business
which is how water companies have been
operating that will be scale of fines
are you are you providing advice on the
level of fine for the level of severity
of problem or is that going to be up to
the ear you highlighted a very good a
very good point in that um
the system was slow you know before if
you had to go to court obviously it's
all based on evidence that you know
whichever whichever method you use uh
but this could be more flexible and
quicker providing you've got the
evidence uh to actually hold on to
account so the police does pay and
obviously there will be there will be
um uh you know guidance on these tools
so just two points for me just to
supplement that well one is there are
sentencing Council guidelines as a
reference point for for the environment
agency or indeed any other environmental
regulator and then just on a point of
clarification the uh the cap lifted
today it doesn't just relate to water
companies it relates to any operator
within scope of the environmental
permitting regulations so actually waste
and other other potential
um
malpractice could be caught by that
excellent final question if I'm a
chairman so the water restoration fund
which I welcome uh without reservation I
think it's an excellent way of ensuring
that some of the issues that Alan was
Raising that the funds raised from fines
does go into resolving the issues not
necessarily the immediate issue but
improving water quality in the area can
you give us any more
um indication of how that will work and
does that that presumably only applies
in relation to fines on from a rising at
water pollution yeah well uh the uh the
criteria you know being worked on now
about exactly you know what would be
most helpful for the water this fund to
go into but obviously it's going to
improving the environment uh and we've
got a big emphasis on catchments now
through everything we're doing through
the integrated plan for water uh and
because really we need to work at a
catchment level if we're really gonna
you know have the cleanest most
wonderful water in a ecologically
healthy Rivers we need to work right the
way up the catchment so there'll be a
focus on it going into to things like
catchment restoration and they're
already some great projects to share but
you know many more of those this would
be a good use for the money determined
by defra but there will be other other
um quite you know categories
um uh that are being looked at right now
to make sure that the money is channeled
to the most useful place to have the
quickest impact as well and potentially
to be used in the area where it was
raised where the money came from sorry I
said it was the last question says it's
supplementary to the last question so
will there be some guidance coming out
of defer as to how these will be
deployed they will
and we've actually we've actually sought
lots of views on this so we've been
talking to lots of different
organizations and groups about where
they think the best use of the money
would be
thank you very much thank you very much
so I think we'll draw stumps now if we
make because I think Mr Hill Minister
for your time could also thank our
colleagues from the business and energy
committee and the environmental audit
Select Committee for their Cameo roles
this morning and uh order